eine erstaunliche ansammlung verrostete
eisenbahnen am horn von afrika ist
wie ein friedhof für züge die allmählich
unter sträuchern gras und erde versinken
ein jahrtausende alte außenposten eines
untergegangenen imperiums dort wurden
schädel gefunden aber nicht den gräbern
offenbar waren es trophäen
ein riesiger festungs komplex zerstört
von übermächtigen kräften
wenn man erfährt was hier geschah laufen
einem kalte schauer über den rücken
[Musik]
und gigantische industrieruinen die im
herzen amerikas vor sich hin rosten
schon dieser kleine bereich lässt die
größe dieser anlage erahnen
[Musik]
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
im mittleren westen der usa am ufer des
michigansees gibt es orte mit einer
faszinierenden vergangenheit
es gibt kaum noch hinweise auf das was
dort geschah man hat nicht viel übrig
gelassen nachdem es vorbei war
das ganze wirkt hier eine streng geheime
anlage die zäune sind mit stacheldraht
gesichert und es stehen merkwürdige
türme herum
welchem zweck dienten diese leer
geräumten plattformen
wenn man fragt sich wofür all diese
dinge verwendet wurden
nicht weit entfernt finden sich hinter
bäumen versteckt die überreste einer
zweiten anlage
sie ist noch rätselhaft eine riesige
betonfläche mit stahltüren die in den
untergrund führen aber es ist unklar was
sich darunter befindet
was wurde hier in der erde indianers
verborgen
und welche verbindung haben die beiden
anlagen zu einem der bedrohlichsten
abschnitte der neueren geschichte
[Musik]
der hier ansässige geschäftsmann virtual
frei setzt sich für die erhaltung der
alten bauten ein
eine verfallene baracke deutet darauf
hin dass sie teil einer
militäreinrichtung aus den 50er jahren
waren
das eine aktive militärbasis war wohnten
hier 90 männer es gibt 17 gebäude
darunter sind das verwaltungsgebäude in
dem der kommandant untergebracht war
zwei baracken ein speisesaal und ein
generator raum der den strom lieferte
der wahre zweck dieser basis war streng
geheim
das neun hektar große areal war mit
stacheldraht eingezäunt
das gab hunde und andere
sicherheitsmaßnahmen
die anwohner wussten wenig über den
komplex und darüber was hier vor sich
ging ein gebäude liefert eine erklärung
für die hohe sicherheitsstufe
[Musik]
das ist das kommunikationszentrum ihr
stapelten sich überall computer
einen hinweis auf das was sich auf den
fünf türmen befand
auf jedem dieser türme war ein anderes
radarsystem angebracht dort oben standen
einmal satellitenschüsseln
sie empfingen informationen die im
kommunikationszentrum ausgewertet wurden
die türme waren plattformen für radar
und kommunikationssysteme
[Musik]
doch was sollte das system überwachen
die antwort findet sich einen guten
kilometer entfernt in einer zweiten
anlage mit seltsamen öffnungen im boden
[Musik]
es ist ein befehls und kontrollzentrum
für äußerst hoch entwickelte
luftabwehrraketen
die beiden anlagen hingen miteinander
zusammen
die erste war die abhör station
die radarstation übermittelt die
koordinaten an die abschussbasis wo die
raketen im verborgenen vorbereitet
wurden
von der zweiten anlage sollten raketen
auf feindliche flugzeuge abgefeuert
werden
[Musik]
doch aus welchem grund sollte der
mittlere westen zur zielscheibe werden
15 kilometer entfernt liegt ein
weitläufiges ehemaliges industriegebiet
diese beiden gegenden mit verlassener
infrastruktur sind geschichtlich eng
miteinander verbunden in dieser region
gibt es viele große und stillgelegte
industrieanlagen
es wirkt wie eine post apokalyptische
vision
was verband diese orte hatte ihre
zerstörung vielleicht dieselbe ursache
darüber gibt die geschichte dieses ortes
abschluss in den 50ern ging es hier
geschäftig zu
das aufstrebende industriegebiet am ufer
des michigansees nach chicago war damals
das herz der amerikanischen industrie
zu dieser zeit wird gary indiana die
stadt des jahrhunderts genannt
[Musik]
ihren aufstieg verdankt sie vor allem
einem produkt
stahl
us deal 1906 sein werk am ufer des
michigansees gründete entwickelte sich
gary in der folge zu einem
industriezentrum und gewann landesweit
an strategischer bedeutung
vor allem für das militär war es sehr
wichtig
im zweiten weltkrieg produzierte das
werk in gary den stahl für schiffe
flugzeuge panzer und andere
rüstungsgüter die stadt wurde aus
verschiedenen gründen als standort
gewählt
einer davon war ihre lage tief im
landesinneren die sie vor feindlichen
angriffen schützt
kein flugzeug aus deutschland japan oder
russland
indianer erreichen und angreifen
doch nach dem zweiten weltkrieg steigen
die spannungen zwischen den usa und der
sowjetunion und ein technologisches und
militärisches kräftemessen beginnt die
sowjets entwickeln einen in großer höhe
fliegenden langstreckenbomber
[Musik]
für einen angriff auf die usa hätten die
sowjets große bombe mit atomwaffen an
bord und dutzende von kampffliegern über
den nordpol in richtung amerikanisches
inland geschickt
ein nuklearer angriff auf gary schien in
den bereich des möglichen zu rücken
indianers abschussrampen und
überwachungsstationen entstehen in einer
zeit in der 150 millionen amerikaner in
reichweite sowjetische atom sprengköpfe
leben
das us militär muss für ihren schutz
sorgen die lösung das raketenprogramm
nike
[Musik]
die nike flugabwehrraketen galten als
die ultimative verteidigung gegen
sowjetische bomber die sich über den
nordpol nähern
[Musik]
am michigan see gibt es damals etwa 20
solcher raketenstellungen
[Musik]
dies ist die raketen anlagen ag c 47
zuständig für die verteidigung der stadt
gary das heute verfallene
kommunikationszentrum war die
einsatzleitung
die entscheidung tatsächlich eine rakete
abzufeuern wäre hier gefallen
sie hätte ihr ziel nicht verfehlen
dürfen sonst hätten viele menschen ihr
leben verloren ich kann mir gar nicht
vorstellen wie es sein muss eine solche
entscheidung zu treffen die atmosphäre
wäre sicher sehr angespannt gewesen
[Musik]
die verantwortlichen für den abschuss
einer rakete hatten nur diesen einen
versuch
während sie bei der arbeit eingeschlafen
hätten menschen sterben können
aufgrund des rasanten technologischen
fortschritts während des kalten krieges
wer die ära von lie gc 47 nicht sehr
lange
schon wären sie gebaut wurden
veränderten sich die technologie und die
bedrohung
gegen interkontinentalraketen gab es
keine verteidigung sie kamen mit
überschallgeschwindigkeit quasi aus dem
nichts
diese vormals hochentwickelten
abwehrraketen waren nutzlos und die
anlagen bei gary wurden zu einer
momentaufnahme der geschichte
in den folgenden jahrzehnten wird auch
das stahlwerk in berlin stillgelegt was
weniger am kommunistischen widersacher
liegt als an den gesetzen
kapitalistischer wirtschaft
am ende waren keine atombombe nötig um
alles zu zerstören die ursachen dafür
waren vielmehr rein politische und
wirtschaftliche
raketen stationen waren ebenso
untrennbar mit dem schicksal von gary
verbunden wie die großen stahlwerke
[Musik]
einst ein hochentwickeltes
verteidigungssystem in einer boomenden
wirtschaftsregion wird die anlage nun
von der natur zurückerobert
der ort ist ein denkmal für die
geschwindigkeit des technologischen
fortschritts im kalten krieg
[Musik]
in der grünen weite von northam real
nahe der schottischen grenze stehen die
überreste von bauwerken wie einst den
rand der bekannten welt markierten
britannien stand für etwas unbekanntes
barbarisches es war ein ort der mythen
und sagen
die versprengten überreste von
steinernen fundamenten weisen auf ein
bedeutendes bauwerk in
die städte liegt inmitten von flüssen
und wasser regen es könnten ziemlich
viele menschen dort gelebt haben
doch diese menschen verschwanden bereits
vor langer zeit
die erbauer waren versierte ingenieure
und handwerker von hier hat man einen
weiten überblick über die gegend es war
also vermutlich von militärischer
bedeutung
ein großer schutzwall liegt gerade mal
einen kilometer entfernt
ist wo ist hier sehr bald sollte die
menschen im süden vor denen im norden
schützen
wer also lebte nördlich der mauer
zeitgenössische dokumente beschreiben
ein wildes volk mit bemaltem körper mit
dem es immer wieder zu kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen kommt
für die römer waren diese fremden völker
des nordens bedrohlich und rätselhaft es
war ziemlich beängstigend
dort wurden schädel gefunden aber nicht
in gräbern offenbar warnes prof unter
diesen fundamenten liegt eine gewaltige
und blutige geschichte
[Musik]
was verbindet den durch englands
äußersten norden verlaufenden weil mit
diesem gespenstischen ort
[Musik]
dies ist vin bru länder
wie sein großvater und vater widmet der
archäologe andrew berlin sein ganzes
leben der erforschung dieser
faszinierenden städte
sie erkennen schon viele ihre
geheimnisse je mehr wir freilegen desto
besser können wir nachvollziehen was
hier vor fast 2000 jahren geschah
die alte mauer und die bröckelnden
überreste geben nur einen groben
eindruck von den einstigen ausmaßen der
anlage
[Musik]
dieses gebäude hatte im erdgeschoss 20
räume wirklich beeindruckend
als birdies vater die abgelegenen ruinen
untersucht findet er einen hinweis
darauf wer ihre bewohner waren
wir fanden die überreste einer
feuerstelle und um die 330 schrifttafeln
einige von ihnen konnten wir bergen sie
sind selbst nach 2000 jahren noch lesbar
diese tafeln geben einen einblick in den
alltag der einwohner windel anders
darunter sind erstaunliche inhalte wie
bestellungen von bier und einladungen zu
festen und einige der frühesten
handschriftlichen aufzeichnungen von
frauen in der westlichen welt
doch sie enthüllen auch dass einige
menschen nicht freiwillig hier lebten
in
einigen schreiben die verfasser von
ihrer angst und dem wunsch zurück
anvertrauten ordnung zu sein
welches volk hat vor zwei jahrtausenden
diese wörter in die tafeln geritzt und
warum ist es verschwunden
unfall von window länder gibt es einen
hinweis
[Musik]
in der nähe verläuft von westen nach
osten eine lange gerade straße sie
verweist ob wir da bauen
solche straßen wurden nur von den römern
gebaut
ich stehe auf einem der
hauptverkehrswege der römer flankiert
von mauern gepflastert mit steinen und
dort hinten ist ein großes tor
die lage wenn du landes weist auf einen
militärischen zwecken
es liegt an der grenze zwischen england
und schottland am nördlichsten rand des
römischen reiches das sich einst von
britannien bis in den nahen osten
erstreckt
dolan da war ein militärlager als die
römische armee dieses gebiet eroberte er
baute sie ein vor
es liegt nahe am römischen grenzwall
die anlage erinnert an den riesigen
einfluss den rom damals hatte
für die römer lag britannien jenseits
der bekannten welt es gab viele
spekulationen über dieses rätselhafte
und geheimnisvolle land
vor allem fürchteten sie die
kriegerischen barbaren aus dem norden
diese völker die bemalten lateinisch
fiktiv woraus die bezeichnung pickten
entstand man hielt sie für unzivilisiert
aber achtete sie als furchtlose krieger
ihre
ängste waren begründet die letzten
aufzeichnungen zur neunten römischen
legion in britannien stammen aus dem
jahr 108 es wird angenommen dass sie von
den kriegern aus dem norden ausgelöscht
wurde in die kleine region ist nicht
gerade klein sie umfasst tausende männer
die bedrohung hinter der grenze hat die
hier stationierten soldaten sicher
zutiefst verängstigt
[Musik]
der schutz den die römer gegen die
nördlichen ständer errichteten ist auch
heute noch sichtbar
in der ferne sieht man wie der ball sich
durch die landschaft schlängelt jede
natürliche formation wurde zu seiner
verstärkung genutzt
derweil verläuft durchs gesamte land von
küste zu küste
dies ist der hadrianswall 1 117
kilometer langes verteidigungssystem
einer der berühmtesten kaiser roms ließ
in
baumwipfeln hadrian legte großen wert
auf die sicherung der grenzen des
römischen reichs und gab auch den limes
britta nicos in auftrag
als hadrian im jahr 122 britannien
besucht will er einen schutz des
römischen gebiets vor den stämmen des
nordens
hier sind wir am hadrianswall wurde in
nicht einmal zehn jahren von 15.000
soldaten in schweißtreibender arbeit
erbaut sein zweck war es die menschen
auf dem gebiet des römischen reichs vor
den barbaren im norden zu schützen
die römischen baumeister nutzen die
gegebenheiten zu ihrem vorteil
in vielen stellen haben die römer die
landschaft geschickten ihre
verteidigungsanlage integriert
einen größeren abschnitt bildet der eine
mächtige felsformationen die auch ohne
eine zusätzliche mauer schwer zu
überwinden ist
all das nur um die rebellischen pickten
abzuwehren
es ist auch ein ausdruck der macht den
die römer über die landschaft und über
die menschen ausübten
damals vor der wahl doppelt so hoch oben
verliefen ein fußweg und zehn selbst
nachts war er noch zu sehen die soldaten
patrouillierten mit fackeln auf ihn das
war eine klare trennlinie zwischen dem
römischen reich und den gebieten
außerhalb
für die völker aus dem norden muss diese
hochentwickelte militärische
befestigungsanlage der eindrucksvollste
anblick gewesen sein den sie je gesehen
hatten
der hadrianswall ist zu seiner zeit die
weltweit stärkste
verteidigungsanlage
[Musik]
über 1500 meter gab es ein meilen kastel
dazwischen jeweils zwei wachtürme die
römer konnten von hier bis zu 60
kilometer weit ins land blicken
von einigen kastellen sind heute noch
die grundmauern erhalten
wenn du lande gehört jedoch nicht zu
diesem grenzposten seine ruinen befinden
sich mehr als einen kilometer südlich
des hadrianswall
vor 2000 jahren war dieses kastell ein
betriebsamer ort
[Musik]
hier lebten damals zwischen zweieinhalb
und 7000 menschen
sie kommen aus regionen wie dem heutigen
belgien deutschland oder der schweiz es
lebten sogar menschen aus nordafrika
hier
ausgrabungen zeigen window länder war
zweigeteilt
es bestand aus dem kastell selbst und
einer geschäftigen stadt
wenn sie nicht den wall bewachten
verbrachten die soldaten dort ihre
freizeit
in der stadt lebten die soldaten mit
ihren frauen und kindern
sie betrieben landwirtschaft und ging
auf die jagd es war eine echte kleine
gemeinschaft nicht nur eine militärische
einrichtung
hat derweil seinen zweck erfüllt oder
konnten die pisten in überwinden
[Musik]
bis ins vierte jahrhundert hinein
unternehmen die römer erhebliche
anstrengungen zur verteidigung der
nördlichsten region ihres imperiums
danach sinkt das interesse an kriegen in
fernen ländern
das römische reich beginnt zu zerfallen
und so sind auch wenn du landers tage
gezählt bevor die römer abziehen wollen
sie ihre schrifttafeln zerstören
sie zündeten feuer an doch es begann zu
regnen und nichts verbrannte als wir die
stelle 2000 jahre später fanden lagen
dort noch immer die schrifttafeln
sie zeichnen ein sehr detailliertes und
farbiges bild wie wir es durch nichts
anderes bekommen könnten und lüften
einige der geheimnisse von window landa
[Musik]
heute noch erinnern wenn du lander und
der hadrianswall an die macht und den
eroberungsdrang des römischen reiches
[Musik]
es ist ein beeindruckendes zeugnis der
militärischen architektur und der macht
eines weltreiches aber auch seines
scheiterns
die römer schafften es nicht ganz
britannien zu unterwerfen
[Musik]
im osten äthiopiens am horn von afrika
legt die stadt die rede er findet man
eine ansammlung ausrangierte relikte
[Musik]
es ist ein seltsamer anblick an diesem
ort wimmelte es früher von menschen doch
nun ist er verlassen alles geschäftige
leben ist verschwunden
das gibt dem ganzen etwas gespenstisches
bei näherer betrachtung entdeckt man
einen klaren europäischen einfluss
[Musik]
überall findet man schilder mit
französischer aufschrift lokomotiven
waggons und gleise
eine riesige werkstatt voller staub und
50 jahre alten ölverschmierten drei
bänken und ein grund angestrichenes
verlassenes bahnhofsgebäude von dem die
farbe abblättert
offenbar war dieser ort einst der
knotenpunkt eines wichtigen
schienennetzes
den ausmaßen nach zu schließen wurde
hier jede menge geld investiert aber
jetzt ist alles vom rost zerfressen
es ist ein paradies für
eisenbahnliebhaber dort gibt es züge und
schilder und alles ist von historischem
wert
[Musik]
wenn eine bahnlinie stillgelegt wird
werden für gewöhnlich die züge und die
restliche ausrüstung verkauft
doch hier wurde alles zurückgelassen was
steckt dahinter
die geschichte dieses eisenbahn
friedhofs führt zurück zum ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts damals hatte
ein mann eine vision mine liegt der
zweite kaiser von äthiopien
ist ein karges land ohne christen aber
es verfügt über große mengen natürlicher
ressourcen die nutzen aber nur etwas
wenn sie abgebaut werden
die jahrhundertwende interessierte sich
keine männer liegt dafür was anderen
ländern zum trotz schritt verhalten
das waren die impulsgeber in
großbritannien oder den usa
urbanisierung und industrialisierung ein
wichtiger teil davon war die eisenbahn
minute hatte die version eines
wegweisenden bauprojekt die
eisenbahnlinie
sie sollte die äthiopische hauptstadt
addis abeba und andere wichtige
handelszentren mit dem hafen von
dschibuti am golf von aden verbinden
eine direkte verbindung zur küste für
den export der waren
[Musik]
dies sind die überreste des bahnhofs von
dir
einem wichtigen knotenpunkt von mannix
eisenbahnlinie
er wurde im europäischen stil erbaut
der 67 jahre alte basaliom arbeitet
schon sein ganzes leben hier und weiß
alles über die reservoir bevor er den
job antreten konnte musste er
französisch lernen
[Musik]
nachdem wir die sprache gelernt hatten
konnten wir herkommen und für die bahn
arbeiten
alles wurde auf französisch abgewickelt
hier haben wir die buchhaltung
die gepäckaufbewahrung und das büro des
bahn inspektors
alles ist auf französisch geschrieben
als mini liegt der zweite die bahnlinie
plant konkurrieren europäische länder um
die kontrolle über afrika der kaiser hat
gerade erst eine invasion durch die
italiener verhindert also beschließt er
den auftrag für das bauprojekt an
frankreich zu geben
die franzosen begann 1897 mit dem bau
der kopfbahnhof in die radar wird 1904
eröffnet und verhilft der stadt schnell
zu wachstum
da war wurde wegen der bahnlinie
gegründet
auf ihr wurden sowohl passagiere als
auch waren befördert
die züge kamen aus addis abeba hierher
von hier transportierten sie waren zum
hafen von dschibuti
dauer hat die hre dabei lag im
hinterland durch die bahnlinie wurde es
zu einem wichtigen knotenpunkt für
reisende und handelsgüter
das gleiche geschah überall auf der welt
ein kleines dorf liegt an einem
strategisch wichtigen ort dann wird eine
bahnlinie dorthin gebaut plötzlich
wächst das dorf zu einer betriebsamen
stadt mit geschäften und einer
florierenden wirtschaft
vier jahre nach mit alex tod wird die
bahnlinie im jahr 1917 fertiggestellt
die ehemals lange und gefährliche reise
an die küste dauert nun nur noch 36
stunden
17 hatte äthiopien ein hochfrequentes
eisenbahnnetz für den transport von
menschen und gütern zu seinen hochzeiten
durch nicht um diesen bahnhof täglich
bis zu 4000 passagiere und um die 1250
tonnen fracht
[Musik]
rassentrennung wie es die damals in
vielen ländern gab wurde in äthiopien
nicht geduldet dort saßen europäer und
afrikaner im selben abteil
hunderte schwarze und weiße menschen
reisten jeden tag zusammen von ihr ab
mit seiner vision für äthiopien ist mit
seiner zeit voraus doch der eisenbahn
friedhof liste auf schließen dass der
plan des kaisers nicht ganz aufging
am dritten oktober 1935 fallen auf
befehl benito mussolinis zwei
italienische arien ins land ein
nicht einmal ein jahr später schließen
sie sich bei die hre das zusammen
äthiopien ist nun in der hand der
faschisten
der zweite weltkrieg wurde auch in
äthiopien ausgetragen das gesamte land
sowie die eisenbahn wurden von den
italienischen faschisten übernommen sie
transportierten mit ihr soldaten waren
und waffen darunter auch panzer
1941 wird äthiopien von den alliierten
befreit
doch die eisenbahn verliert an bedeutung
nach dem ende des krieges kam es zu
einer weltweiten rezession
die bahnlinie verfiel es wurde nichts
nennen sie investiert
[Musik]
1977 musste die bahnlinie einen weiteren
rückschlag einstecken
somalische truppen fehlen in äthiopien
ein und besetzten auch den bahnhof von
der dauer sie zerstörten große teile des
bahnnetzes und der betrieb wurde noch
weiter eingeschränkt und es kommt noch
schlimmer
1985 ereignet sich ein verheerender
unfall
als ein zug über eine brücke fuhr
entgleiste er und mehr als 400 der 1000
passagiere starben
es war das schwerste zugunglück afrikas
und hatte weitreichende auswirkungen auf
den bahnbetrieb
heute verläuft neben der alten eine
brandneue linie und der alte kopfbahnhof
in die reha ist verlassen
[Musik]
die bahnverbindung zwischen äthiopien
und dschibuti steht für einen traum der
darauf wartet
wirklichkeit zu werden
[Musik]
es gibt pläne das schienennetz zu
sanieren die regierung hofft damit die
industrialisierung voranzutreiben
bis 2025 will sie die arme
landwirtschaftlich geprägte nation mit
über 100 millionen einwohnern in ein
schwellenland transformiert
[Musik]
im herzen betont stehen ruinen die auf
den ersten blick keinem bestimmten zweck
dienen
[Musik]
dieses große areal gibt dem betrachter
zunächst keinen klaren anhaltspunkt der
erkennen lässt worum es sich handelt
aus der luft bekommt man einen besseren
überblick über die gesamte architektur
man erkennt rechtwinklige formen und die
umrisse von gebäuden
aus dem boden ragen verschiedene
seltsame gebilde
alles ist von pflanzen überwuchert
es gibt beton hügel mit großen öffnungen
doch es ist unklar wohin sie führen
lange tunnel verlaufen in alle möglichen
richtungen
es ist wie ein dunkles labyrinth
drinnen es ist düster und klamm es
riecht muffig ein wirklich gruseligen
ort
[Musik]
überall findet man kampfspuren
es gab dort ganz sicher einen schweren
angriff
es dominiert der eindruck von verwüstung
löcher in decken und wänden überall
schutt
wenn man erfährt was hier geschah und
laufen einem kalte schauer über den
rücken
[Musik]
der ursprung dieser ruinen liegt in
einer unruhigen und blutigen zeit der
europäischen geschichte
was hier geschah bescheinigte den
untergang eines großen reiches
im späten neunzehnten jahrhundert liegt
diese gegend am rande des weitläufigen
russischen kaiserreichs
ende des jahrhunderts nehmen die
spannungen zwischen den supermächten
europas zu und die grenzregion sieht
sich einer neuen gefahr ausgesetzt
[Musik]
deutschland bestand zuvor aus vielen
kleineren königreichen und herzogtümer
1871 schlossen sie sich zum deutschen
reich zusammen zum ersten mal grenzte
das russische reich im westen an einem
großen nationalstaat
[Musik]
wilhelm der zweite der 1888 deutscher
kaiser wird hat wenig interesse an einer
allianz mit russland in vorbereitung auf
einen drohenden krieg errichten die
russen die festung von kaunas russisch
cosmo
[Musik]
der russische zar mochte festungen unter
ihm entstanden einige festung städte in
die russland einen großen teil seiner
militärausgaben investierte
1882 wird mit dem bau begonnen
den historiker weil das rugbys
fasziniert die komplexe geschichte
dieses ortes ist
eine der grössten russischen festungen
in europa in diesem teil lebten und
arbeiteten
250 soldaten
und im kriegsfall kämpften sie hier
es war das goldene zeitalter des
festungsbau
das ausmaß dieser anlage ist wirklich
enorm
wir sind auf der rechten seite der
festung dort sieht man die stadt kaunas
zu deren schutz sie diente
alle straßen führen die stadt man konnte
sie nicht umfahren
außerdem gab es eine bahnverbindung auf
der in kriegszeiten truppen und
nachschub transportiert werden konnten
jonas ist so wichtig für die russen dass
sie nicht eins sondern neun fonds baum
man muss die verteidigung so aufbauen
dass es von keiner seite einen sicheren
zugang gibt
zur zeit des baus war das alles
hochmodernen doch in den 1890 jahren
änderte sich die technik sehr schnell
hoppla wir alle paar jahre musste die
festung wegen des technischen
fortschritts umgebaut werden die
geschützte veränderten sich und man
stand immer gefährlicheren bedrohungen
gegenüber
[Musik]
sehr bald machten neue waffen flugzeuge
und panzer solche befestigungsanlagen
obsolet
[Musik]
als in europa der erste weltkrieg
ausbricht bringen neue waffen die
festung an ihre grenzen
der erbitterte konflikt zwischen dem
deutschen und dem russischen reich wird
auch in kaunas ausgefochten die
deutschen setzen alles daran die
strategisch wichtige festung zu erobern
[Musik]
die deutschen verstärkten ihre nördliche
flanke und standen im august
1915 vor den toren von kaunas
zehn tage lang wurde erbittert um die
fonds 1 2 und 3 gekämpft vor vier galt
als das am schwersten einnehmen bahre
die russen hofften dass die deutschen
ihre angriffe dort konzentrieren würden
doch das taten sie nicht
wenn man ein oder zwei fonds verlor war
das nicht zwangsläufig das ende aber
wenn empfindliche punkte zerstört wurden
vier die gesamte festung
die deutsche armee greift mit ihren
höher entwickelten waffen die
schwächsten bereiche der festung an die
russen haben keine chance
die schrecklichste dieser neuen waffen
war ein geschütz namens dicke berta es
feuerte 42 cm granaten und war bis dahin
das größte je gebaute artilleriegeschütz
man sieht noch die folgen des beschusses
das ganze gebäude wurden zerstört
alle menschen in der nähe wurden getötet
sowas überlebte man nicht
sobald sie durchgebrochen waren fielen
die deutschen in die stadt 1 und
eroberten sie trotz vieler jahre der
planung und des baus fiel die festung
bereits nachdem sie wenige tage intensiv
attackiert worden war
bis zum ende des krieges besetzen die
deutschen einen großen teil der towns
doch auch nach ihrem rückzug geht das
leiden der bevölkerung weiter
als sie weg waren entstand ein
machtvakuum
es kam zu bürgerkriegen bevor litauen
1918 seine unabhängigkeit wieder
erlangte doch selbst nach all dieser
gewalt stand kaunas und seiner festung
die schlimmste zeit noch bevor
im zweiten weltkrieg kommt es in der
festung zu furchtbaren gräueltaten
die fonds wurden zu schauplätzen
scheußlicher kriegsverbrechen der
deutschen vor allem an der
zivilbevölkerung
sie lagen absatz und versteckt
[Musik]
sich sehr gut für massenhinrichtungen
es trifft vor allem die jüdische
bevölkerung litauens
vor nummer 4 spielte im holocaust eine
große rolle
daher wurden die menschen gebracht um
hingerichtet zu werden
an einem einzigen tag werden hier mehr
als 1800 juden erschossen
auch in den anderen force von callas
werden menschen ermordet
denn vor neun wurden die schlimmsten
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
verübt wir wurden zehntausende getötet
[Musik]
gegen ende des krieges erfüllen die
fonds ein letztes mal ihren eigentlichen
zweck als die deutsche armee versucht
sich gegen die vorrückenden truppen
stalins zu verteidigen
[Musik]
die ford hatten den sowjetischen panzer
brigaden nichts entgegenzusetzen im
ersten weltkrieg waren sie nach elf
tagen gefallen nun dauerte es nicht mal
45 minuten
die deutschen wurden zwar aus litauen
vertrieben doch das land erhielt seine
unabhängigkeit dies sich vor dem krieg
erkämpft hatte nicht zurück nun wurde es
ein halbes jahrhundert lang von den
sowjets besetzt
[Musik]
erst als 1990 der eiserne vorhang
verschwindet wird litauen wieder eine
eigenständige nation
inzwischen sind die verlassenen force
mahnmale einer leidvollen geschichte
wir stehen nicht nur die überreste der
verteidigungsanlagen vor neun ist eine
gedenkstätte für die opfer
nationalsozialistischer und
stalinistischen verbrechen
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen um
verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
vom erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]